[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity justice in America now the
Democrats continue to stoop to new lows
in smearing president Trump and Attorney
General William Barr recklessly calling
for impeachment even jail time
all while fueling chaos across Capitol
Hill
take a look you know what I think is
important is to recognize that 10
million people said that we need to hold
this president accountable I think that
speaks volumes like my friend Reggie
said impeachable process was created for
someone like President Donald Trump the
Constitution of the United States of
America to do our duty
we must impeach let the Senate do what
they may we have to do what we must now
I will say having obstructed the Justice
Department the investigation and now
obstructing Congress the case for
impeachment gains weight to ensure that
we get that report because we have
lawful responsibilities constitutional
responsibilities to to engage in one of
which is possibly impeachment how can we
impeach without getting the documents
and like clockwork the media is doing
the Democrats bidding along the way
here's just a small sample take a look
you're defending the most corrupt
Attorney General
I mean since John Michell like it's bad
your article is gonna look
extraordinarily stupid and you're going
to look like it no reason the sycophant
it's just it's really embarrassing
joining me now for reaction Fox News
contributor Rachel Campos Duffy and
Trump 2020 national press secretary
Kayleigh mackaninee thank you both for
joining us
Rachel I want to start with you the
topic here the special is justice in
America Muller does a report the
Attorney General puts it out with
everything except what's he's supposed
you know prohibited by law and they want
to hold him in contempt they want him to
go to jail essentially they might
impeach the president is that justice in
America it's not and you know you had
Joe Scarborough there saying that it
they look at that the Republicans look
incredibly stupid well the Democrats are
going to look not only incredibly stupid
but incredibly corrupt when bar gets to
the bottom of how this investigation
started because we know that that the
dossier was dirty we know that that was
used to to spy on the Trump campaign and
now we're hearing that the FBI knew that
it was dirty before they gave it to the
FISA judges so this is very serious
stuff and I think part of this is not
just to sully the President and make it
look like he's hiding something because
they're still clinging to this collusion
and obstruction stuff but also to get to
Sully bar because they know something's
coming out and it's not just what's
happening at the FBI or the corruption
of the FBI this goes all the way to the
top this goes all the way to Obama Biden
Valerie Jarrett the White House that's
what they're really worried about it
Rachel I think you're right I think they
are so worried about the Inspector
General report in what attorney general
bar is coming with but Caylee we had
Adam Schiff he's on the cover of
Newsweek for goodness sake
and he's out there saying that it gained
weight the idea of impeachment gained
weight are you kidding me
this guy shouldn't even have a security
clearance I can't believe he's even in
Congress the way he told the American
people for two years what the molar
report was going to report and then it
didn't right and this is the guy who
said he had ample evidence of
illusion we've yet to see that and we've
yet to see him held to account
absolutely laughable the notion of
impeachment that montage of clips she
played also laughable because Democrats
are out there saying Oh president Trump
is goading impeachment what an what an
absurd assertion the only ones goading
impeach Minar the very democrats that
you saw say impeachment over and over
and over again it's absurd the American
people know it it's why sixty-five
percent oppose impeachment according to
Harvard Harris so they're going to go
down this road and they're going to do
so at their own detriment as we approach
the twenty twenty election and Trump has
so many great results to sell and all
they have is investigations that are
meritless you know earlier in the show
trey Gowdy said that one of his biggest
disappointments in his eighth year in
eight years in Congress is the way that
the national media treated the imbalance
I mean they just they they looked at
Republicans and treated them totally
different than Democrats
Rachel what's your take on how the
national media is covering this story
and the reaction of how a bar is handled
this Muller report absolutely proof that
the media is in the tank with the
Democrats on their bias is on display
but Caylee hits a really good point I
mean if you think back Jason to the
midterms they weren't talking about
impeachment at all they were to focus on
issues and that's why I think they won
but now they're back to impeachment and
I think this is very risky because it is
going to certainly rev up their base and
it's also revving up and angering the
Republican base but what's left is the
swing voters the swing voters in the
states like Pennsylvania and Wisconsin
in Ohio places where the president has
absolutely delivered on jobs on the
economy on were energy independent we're
so strong we're finally after decades
taking on China these giant cheaters and
we couldn't do that if we weren't in
this strong economic position we got all
right now so this is a time for the
country to unite the American people
know that we're stronger fighting China
on these tariffs when we're united and
they see the Democrats focus on this and
when the elections come along Jason
they're gonna go especially these swing
voters they're gonna look at at the
Democrats and say what have they done
for me stupid investigation
that they said baller Muller was the
final word the final word comes out and
now they're gonna keep going or Donald
Trump who has delivered in spades to
every promise okay Kaleigh impeachment
in contempt is that the winning message
for America real quick we've only got
about 20 seconds left
absolutely not look I go to all the
presidents rally 75% of the registrants
firm are El Paso rally were Democrats or
swing voters that's amazing when I talk
to them in the lines they talk about
health care they talk about the economy
they talk about the issues impeachment
is last on their radar no I think you're
absolutely right Caylee and Rachel thank
you very much for joining us tonight we
do appreciate it